foreign
digital marketing enthusiasts are you
ready to take a marketing game to the
next level then you have come to the
right place in today's world digital
marketing is a king and if you want to
stand out from the crowd you must have
the right certifications under your belt
but with so many options out there it
can be tough to know where to start
that's where we come in we have scarred
through the internet and talk to experts
in the field and done our research to
bring you the top 10 digital marketing
certifications you need to know about
whether you are seasoned marketing Pro
or just starting out these
certifications will help you stay ahead
of the curve and take your skills to the
next level
so sit back grab a cop cup of coffee and
get ready to learn about top 10 digital
marketing certifications that will
transform your career to get more such
videos then subscribe to our Channel and
like this video on that note as for this
which of the following is not a common
digital marketing channel option a email
marketing option b social media
marketing
option C print advertising and option D
search engine optimization comment down
your answers and earn a thumbs up from
Simply learn but before we begin let me
ask you again are you ready to dive into
the world of digital marketing and take
your career to the new heights then look
no further then simply learns digital
marketing specialist Masters program
this program is co-created with
Facebook's collaboration with Google and
omcp in this exciting and comprehensive
training course you will learn
everything you need to know to succeed
in the fast phase world of digital
marketing from SEO to social media
marketing to content marketing and email
marketing you will gain a deep
understanding of the strategies and
tactics used by top Professionals in the
field but this isn't just an ordinary
program you will learn from industry
experts through interactive online
sessions and you will have access to
practical assignments and real world
project that will help you apply your
learning in the real world and the best
part at the end of this program you will
earn a coveted Master certifications
recognized by top companies around the
globe so why wait enroll now in simply
learns digital marketing specialist
Masters program and take your career to
the next level
so without any further Ado let's dive
into our top 10 digital marketing
certification at number one we have Duke
universities digital media and marketing
certification this professional level
online course will prepare you to take
the online marketing certified
professional omcp exam to earn the
highly valued certification it is an
online course ideal for digital
marketing professionals with a few years
of experience with 350 hours of
self-paced instructions study time that
students can compete over a 12-month
period at just
3195 dollars Duke University offer this
course for professionals interested in
attaining the industry-leading omcp
certification student must pass the
digital marketing certified associate
dmca module and receive that
certification before moving on to the
advanced modules which covers topics
like mobile marketing SEO paid search
and content Marketing in mod app they
will also be exposed to the popular
digital marketing tools like HootSuite
MailChimp and Google ads Hands-On work
through Labs that includes access to
mimic Pro and mimic social allows
students to hone their skills without
needing access to their real platforms
then at number two is the HubSpot
inbound marketing certification the
demand for digital marketing
professionals has skyrocketed in recent
years and companies are constantly
seeking individuals who possess the
skill and knowledge to develop and
execute effective inbound marketing
campaigns with HubSpot inbound marketing
certification you will gain the skills
needed to develop an inbound marketing
strategy create engaging content and
effectively measure and analyze results
this certification requires passing an
exam with minimum score of 75 percent
and covers top topics such as the
inbound marketing methodology buyers
persona content creation social media
marketing lead nurturing email marketing
and analytics by completing this
certification Learners acquire valuable
skills including developing a
comprehensive inbound marketing strategy
creating an engaging content optimizing
social media channels and measuring
campaign performance this certification
opens up various job opportunities
including inbound marketing Specialists
digital marketing manager and content
marketer and social media strategist
with average salaries ranging from fifty
thousand dollars to hundred thousand
dollars annually while this
certification is free users need to
subscribe to HubSpot speed plan to
access hubspot's marketing Hub or other
marketing tools next at number three we
have digital marketing specialist by
LinkedIn
it is taught by various experienced
professionals linkedin's online course
provides a no pressure environment for
entry-level marketers wishing to build
their knowledge of digital marketing
this is an online course with at almost
20 hours of on-demand videos broken down
into 11 modules at a price of 29.99
dollars per month or a 19.99 paid
annually for access to all LinkedIn
learning courses this is an ideal course
for people with little to no experience
with digital marketing it provides a
comprehensive overview of all the
leading digital marketing channels
including Google ads PPC SEO email and
social marketing students will also get
a basic introduction to Google analytics
content marketing Facebook and Instagram
and even learn the fundamentals of
graphic design using Adobe products each
video modules includes a quiz to test
how much you have learned and you will
receive a certificate upon completion of
all the modules
at number 4 we have digital marketing
Institute certification this digital
marketing certification is a
collaborative effort between the
American Marketing Association AMA and
the digital marketing Institute DMI
students who pass this exam will be dual
certified with two professional
credentials the PCM digital marketing
and certified digital marketing
professional with the rise of social
media and other digital platforms
companies need skilled professionals to
create and execute effective digital
marketing campaigns job roles such as
digital marketing manager social media
marketing manager SEO marketing manager
and a Content Marketing Manager are
available with an average salary ranging
from fifty thousand dollars to hundred
thousand dollars per year this program
covers all aspects of digital marketing
including SEO PPC social media marketing
email marketing content marketing and
digital strategy the training is
delivered online allowing individuals to
learn at their own pace this program
includes access to expert trainers real
world case studies practical exercises
and quizzes to test understanding the
cost varies based on location and
delivery method ranging from one
thousand five hundred dollars to two
thousand five hundred dollars making it
a worthwhile investment for anyone
seeking to succeed in digital marketing
field at number five on our list is
simply learn Sports graduate program in
digital marketing simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing it is in collaboration with
but University and meta blueprint that
equips Learners with the essential
skills and knowledge needed to access in
the digital marketing industry with the
growing importance of online marketing
businesses require professionals to
implement and manage digital marketing
campaigns effectively the program
provides certifications recognized
globally and offers Learners a
significant advantage in the job market
this program covers digital marketing
fundamentals SEO sem social media
marketing content marketing email
marketing web analytics and mobile
marketing preparing learners for various
job roles in the digital marketing field
the program also focuses on developing
essential skills such as strategic
thinking data analysis creative problem
solving communication and Leadership
this program utilizes a range of tools
including Google analytics Google ads
Facebook ads YouTube ads LinkedIn ads
HootSuite and SE ranking Etc to give
Learners a hands-on experience with the
tools and Technologies used in the
industry the program price is 3500 with
the and with an option for Learners to
pay in installment and the classes are
organized or weekends allowing Learners
to complete the courses while
maintaining full-time job overall simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing is an excellent choice for
anyone looking to break into digital
marketing industry or take their careers
to the next level
at number six we have semrush SEO
toolkit certification semrush SEO
toolkit certification is an online
program designed to help digital
marketers and SEO professionals enhance
their skills and knowledge in using
semrush a popular SEO tool the program
consists of three courses covering
various SEO topics such as keyword
research on-page optimization backlink
analysis and computers analysts this
certification offers Learners the
opportunity to learn about experienced
SEO professionals and access a community
of Learners upon completion of the
program Learners receive a certificate
job roles requiring semrush skills
include SEO manager digital marketing
manager content writing manager and
marketing director according to the
glass tool the average salary for an SEO
manager is 76 000 per year while this
digital marketing managers earns an
average of 90 000 per year
this program cost around 119 dollars and
is self-paced allowing Learners to
complete it at their own convenience
this program is an excellent investment
for those looking to improve their
search engine optimization efforts and
increase online visibility and it
provides Learners with valuable skills
and knowledge in using semrush to
achieve these goals
next up at number seven is the Columbia
business school digital marketing
certification program this digital
marketing certification offered by
emirators and Columbia business school
provides a comprehensive initiation to
the field of digital marketing so if you
are looking for a course that's a little
more in-depth but won't take you to the
best parts of the year to complete then
the Columbia business school offers a
digital marketing program spanning just
three months requiring as little as two
to four hours of study per week taking
place entirely online and curriculum is
divided into 14 modules covering topics
such as key marketing channels and
principles customer Behavior content
marketing and messaging and digital
marketing Matrix this content is
delivered through live online teaching
sessions and Q A's discussion groups and
video lectures you will also try your
hands at real world applications and
simulation this course is ideal for
entry-level marketing professionals at a
price of thousand and two fifty dollars
in all this is a highly interactive and
comprehensive course that will give you
a credible digital marketing
certification for your CV next up in
line is HubSpot content marketing
certification the HubSpot content
marketing certification is a
comprehensive training program that
provides individuals with necessary
skills to create and promote compelling
content and certification which is
designed to meet the growing demand for
Content marketing skills in the market
as more and more companies are looking
to create and promote their content and
reach their target audience this program
covers 11 lessons that includes topics
such as understanding content marketing
creating a Content strategy optimizing
content for search engines and measuring
content marketing Roi Additionally the
certification program teaches Learners
various tools and Technologies used in
content marketing with this certificate
individuals can pursue various job roles
such as content marketing manager
content writer social media manager
digital marketing manager and more the
cost of the certification program is 195
dollars and it includes access to all
courses material quizzes and the
certification exam the certification
exam consists of 60 multiple choice
questions and a passing score of 75
percent or higher is required to earn
this certification after that at number
nine is the hoot suit social marketing
certification this would suit social
marketing certification is an online
program that trains individuals in
social media marketing businesses
recognize this importance of a building
the online presence to connect with
their target audience and drive Revenue
making a social media marketing skills
highly sort of this program covers
topics such as strategy content creation
Community Management at advertising and
analytics it comprises of six modules
with video lessons quizzes and practical
exercises upon completion individuals
can pursue rules such as social media
managers digital marketing managers and
marketing coordinators with salaries
ranging from forty thousand dollars to
hundred thousand dollars annually
this program offers ongoing support and
resources and participants can access
materials from anywhere in the world it
will cost you around 199 US Dollars and
provides a certification of completion
The Hoot suit social marketing
certification is valuable investment for
those looking to advance their career in
social media marketing and finally at
number 10 on our list is the Google
analytics certification the Google
analytics certification is a globally
recognized certification that proves an
individual's proficiency and website
analytics with the increasing demand for
data-driven decision making
professionals with this certification
can find employment in various rules
including digital marketing analyst web
analytics manager data analyst and
marketing manager according to the
Glassdoor the average salary for a
digital marketing analyst with Google
analytics skills in the United States is
around 66 000 annually
Fab analytics manager can expect to earn
an average salary of 98 000 annually
while data analyst with Google analytics
skills can earn an average salary of 67
000 and a Google analytics certification
exam which consists of 70 multiple
choice questions to earn the Google's
analytics certification professionals
must demonstrate their Proficiency in
the areas like Google analytics account
creation and administration data
collection and processing configuration
and administration reporting metrics and
dimensions and Analysis tools and
techniques the Google analytics
certification exam cost around 149
dollars and candidates can retake it
after 7 days if they fail to pass it on
the first attempt pursuing the Google
analytics certification can be a
valuable investment for professionals
looking to enhance their digital
marketing and analytics career prospects
so that's it Guys these are the top 10
digital marketing certification that can
help you build your career in digital
marketing remember investing in
certification is not just about adding
another line to your resume it's about
developing the skills and knowledge
necessary to succeed in the digital
marketing industry
I hope this video helped you in making a
career in digital marketing and if you
are already in a digital marketing field
this can help Advance your career
tremendously
so if you like this video and want more
such videos then let us know in the
comment section below also hit that like
button and share it with your peers
until next time stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here